عزيزي سيدي الرئيس الأصدقاء
البوكيمون لدي لك ركوب الدراجات
مرحبا سوتشي
تنهدت أنا siatro من شركات المؤلف ومن أجل
يمكنني لياندرو
ونادي m-1 سوتشي وفي البداية أريدك
مبروك على النتائج
البحث عن التدفقات الطينية في القتال ضد
الجماعات الإرهابية
فاندو التدخين أفاد عربة من النبيذ
في البداية ، تنظف ذيلك
من فيلم uri نجار آخر ولكن على الأقل
لعبة
أهنئكم على حقيقة أن الشعب السوري
يمر بتجارب صعبة للغاية و
تقترب تدريجيا من النهاية
هزيمة لا مفر منها
إرهابي بافو ضيق بعض الفريق في الليل
من uri
أنا مور لا حافة virago الممثل حتى أجرة
أو النصر الكامل الإرشاد
سعيد لرؤيتك في الموقع قبل متلمس
لقد كان مؤلمًا للغاية
روس إلى milichevich عمدة أوديسا وأنا جدا
سعيد لمقابلتك
بعد عامين بأسابيع قليلة
بعد أن شنت روسيا العملية و
الذي يأتي مع اقتصادي ناجح للغاية
تعليقات في مهنة تركت جالسة
يفشل عندما نكون في النهائي لهذه الفترة
لقد تم تحقيق خطوات كبيرة
تمامًا مثل ساحة المعركة
سياسي